BIRT ship the moderator for our fateful
moments panel is well on his way toward
becoming a legend in dallas television
news not in recent years as an on-camera
personality which is our misfortune but
as a person who's been involved in
television since 1953 for 40 years now
most of that time running things from
behind the scenes since 1975 he's been
assignments editor at wfaa-tv before
that he was news director for ten years
earlier in his career he covered every
major bead in town police courts city
hall education he'll tell you about his
own memorable experiences in covering
the assassination and they are memorable
as you'll hear one year after the
assassination he did what seemed to be
the impossible he got an exclusive
television news interview with The
Beatles during their stopover in Dallas
maybe on another day we'll hear how that
was done
impaired has received any number of
awards ap UPI Press Club Awards one from
SMU Southwest Journalism forum he also
has a past president of the Press Club
of Dallas and former president of the
Society of Professional Journalists
perhaps a very recent honor is high on
his personal list he won a Press Club of
Dallas KT award not for his television
work but for writing a column and in the
same contest his son Brett who works on
an opposing TV station in town KDFW won
a Cady Award for his TV reporting it
almost certainly was the first time that
a father and son team have won two
awards in the same year I'm proud to say
the bird attended Southern Methodist
University
he's married the father achieved three
children and grandfather to four bird
ship
thank you thank you very much good to be
here and I would like to say that
without Darwin and the fine people here
at SMU we would not have these digs
because Jim Yul and Warren Bosworth a
couple of other stories decided some
time ago that maybe only on the 30th
anniversary we could get together in
some dark hotel room and and over serve
ourselves and tell stories
well that was an ongoing thing for a
while then but if we started picking up
extra baggage see where everybody wanted
to be there the first thing you know
Darwin said this thing's gonna be a
disaster if we don't take it out on the
hill thank you very much Darwin and all
your people here just really indebted to
you but I like to think that many
careers started at Parkland some ended
but parkland didn't wasn't in existence
until I think it opened in September
1954 we knew it wasn't going to be the
Mayo Clinic we knew that it wasn't to
say the Bethesda Naval no it maybe ended
up more like General Hospital on TV and
I had my connection with it that day
back in 1963 I was at the trademart was
standing by detective he heard something
on the radio he said the President had
been hit I said what with an egg or rock
or what he said he didn't know and about
that time we could hear the live of the
stuff the limousines coming down around
the around the trademart there another
reporter not Jackie Renfro he went out
to the curb and shot it as it passed
that we didn't see anything we well it
so Jackie but all I saw was a foot Lynn
over the back of the limousine there and
so we jumped in the car with a detective
told him take us to Parkland I have
filmed a few scenes outside and went
inside and decided to try to make
contact with the station
I kept pestering this one guy and he
told me that he was going to show me a
new trick with that phone button leave
him alone turned out to be Merryman
Smith
I believe he could have anyhow shortly
thereafter I rented the sheriff Decker
and I said what's it look like sheriff
and he says well you ever seen a deer
hit in the back of the head did nothing
back there I say what I said he can't
live that way and he says and so I
called the station told John Allen I
said tell him on the air that that the
president is dead he has no oh no way he
can live with a little wound he's got in
his head and Allen said I know who'd do
such thing he says you do it so any I
told him well to what I thought sheriff
had told me and I joined 2,500 others
who announced the death of the president
at the same time I like we have a long
list of every first but they we have a
great panel here that some of them are
going to be connected with Parkland some
of on the periphery but they all have a
great story Bob Huffaker was a reporter
with care all D before he became Santa
Claus and he is is one of the finest
reporters around the city in those days
Bob don't tell us what you saw and heard
did thanks Bert I'm not really Santa
Claus but he has a close personal brand
it's good to see a lot of these good
folks like Jimmy Darnell who just set
next to me and I haven't seen him for
decades and Bert as well we had KRLD had
planned our broadcast to begin at Love
Field where there Frank Bluebird and
West wise began Frank described the
arrival of Air Force One and West then
took up the broadcast at lemon and
inward he described the motorcade at
that location and later as you know West
became mayor of Dallas and improved the
image that the city had received during
those days and we were working as some
of the print media people have already
pointed out with tools that certainly
are primitive by today's standards we
Frank and Wes and I were broadcasting on
little Loeb and two-way radios and you
had to hold the switch down or you were
off the air and we had to depend on our
KRLD tower which still spans what is now
KF k DFW downtown so oh and by the way
with the way we took our cues from each
other I had a little transistor radio
hanging around my neck with a earpiece
in it and that was our only means of
communication as long as we were on the
air so I took my cue from West from
Lebanon in wood and then I began my
broadcast from Maine and accurate
downtown long before the motorcade
arrived our object was to stay on the
air until Eddie Barker our news director
who was to cover the matter from the
Trade Mart was to pick it up and at that
point we were to broadcast President
Kennedy's address live on both radio and
television but at this point we were
just on radio
and television was broadcasting some
ridiculous soap opera at the time I took
my cue from Wes and held forth until I
described the passing of the motorcade
and then I kept on continuing with an
analysis of the political reasons for
Kennedy's visit to Texas as long as I
could so that the motorcade would have
time to reach the Trade Mart where ad
Barker would then take over the
broadcast and I was of course still
broadcasting when the when the shots
were fired in Dealey Plaza and I was
totally unaware of that being as some of
the houses select committee analysts
have now told me I was 1,500 feet away
because they've tried desperately to
pick up the shots out of my tape and
have been unsuccessful in that I then
finally after I had held it for as long
as I could and assumed that Eddie must
have been ready to pick it up by then I
stopped my broadcast gave my hat cue and
folded up my gear I had KRL DS only
unmarked mobile unit a sort of a scruffy
Black Mercury Comet station wagon and I
which by the way still are wherever it
is in whatever junkyard it's ended up
probably bears the scars of the people
who crawled all over it when the
motorcade passed I then drove the block
and a half back to our KRLD newsroom
which was still in a small building
outside the main building at the time
and pulled up in front getting ready to
get out of the car and go inside
Warren folks who was doing our 10
o'clock news anchor at the time
an excellent newsman and I wish he were
here Warren came running out the front
door and told me the President had been
shot and taken to Parkland Hospital so I
said we'll grab a camera and let's go it
was at that point that all of us on the
KRLD news team simply began to function
by instinct because all of our plans for
the day had gone out the window and I
then made it out for out to Harry Hines
Boulevard faster than I have ever made
it anywhere else ran into a big
cardboard box on the way out and knocked
it out of the street then got to the
hospital where they had just cordoned
off the entrance so that we could not
get back to the emergency room through
normal channels but being a younger much
younger newsman I simply took that old
car and which was sort of new at the
time and jumped curbs all the way across
the parking lot to get back to the
emergency room I had covered the
emergency room and the police beat a lot
as a reporter for KRLD got about a
minute there but that's it no you got
another minute Oh another minute okay
Bert thanks for the cue I I then
broadcast and stayed on the air as much
as possible we stayed on the air that
was what we were trying to do keep
information coming as much as possible
and Warren folks and I alternated on the
microphone while the other one of us
would go in and and meet the little
press conferences given by Malcolm
Kilduff inside and we were giving
Connolly's condition and what
information was being released at the
time and I was interviewing Ralph
Yarborough congressman ray Roberts
people like that who were still walking
stunned around the back entrance of the
emergency room and when the when Eddie
finally announced that the president had
had had died we had not found it out
even there outside the emergency room
yet and I was interviewing Jim right at
the time and it was at that point that I
finally became so emotional about it
that I could hardly go on and I simply
said I know no one wants to say anything
at a time like this congressman right
but do you have anything to say and I
handed him the mic and Jim Wright prayed
into my microphone I have always liked
him ever since let's say Amy into that
that's right they involved and I held
forth there until the till the hearse
finally departed later on my beat was
the Dallas Police Headquarters where I
broadcast the live CBS coverage of the
shooting of Oswald among other things
along with Nelson Benton our associate
from CBS thank you thank you very much
next we have the other half of the
Darnell Welch team and Jim and Darnell
came to work for us I work for b.a.p kxs
in the early 60s and they undo he was
going to be a great newsman because I
taught him everything he knows Jimmy
Jimmy buddy you remember from those days
well of course I was out of love fell as
Bob well she said earlier to get the
president coming in from Fort Worth and
then I was in the motorcade and there
were four of us in the and the Dallas
bureau then for Channel five News and
dandle ones was on the street I think he
had come in on his day off I'm not sure
Dan's here but uh whenever the shots
were fired I thought it was police
motorcycles backfiring I could not
imagine that there had been any kind of
shooting in spite of all the publicity
that had been attended to
to the president's visit and but I
bailed out because my bureau chief Jimmy
Kerr had said bail out in case there's
trouble and I thought well okay but I
don't know what that means since I don't
expect anything and so that's what I did
I bailed out and shot the chaos as much
as I could and our office was in the
County Courthouse which is right across
the street from the Texas Book
Depository my car was still at Love
Field but I did have the office so I had
unlimited access to phone and to film
but I had no car also we only had one
sound camera in the entire Dallas in in
the entire city of Dallas for Channel
five that I remember and Bob Welsh
course had it out of trademark for the
speech so we had to wait until a sound
camera came over from Fort Worth before
we could do any interviews and by that
time Henry Koch John with NBC had joined
me and we were kind of interviewing
people as Jim Featherston brought him
into the press room for his own
interviews and we would take them and do
the interviews some of these people
including a Polaroid picture that
someone shot then after we got through
with that we decided well I've got to
get my car out at Love Field I can't do
anything else till I get my car so Floyd
bright from Fort Worth took me out to
get my car well we got out there and it
was obvious that it was about time for
the president's body to be brought back
out there because of all the security
and everything that was in place so I
climbed up a ladder that the police had
put up to get on the roof of one of the
Air Cargo buildings and here looking
down on Air Force One and in the
foreground was this police officer who
was up there standing guard and then off
to my right comes these limousines and
this hearse and I'm standing there and
they unload they load the president's
body on the plane
and I turn around I climbed down the
ladder and I turn around and this deputy
police chief for the Dallas Police
Department says let me have that that's
sacrilegious poor choice of words but
that's what he said
so I hand him the fam and then my bureau
chief Jimmy Kurt apparently spent a good
part of the rest of the day that the
president was assassinated trying to
retrieve this fam to this day it's never
been seen except there's one person has
told me that he's heard that has been
seen on the west coast or somewhere
thank you thank you very much Jim you
the only police reporter the Morning
News ever had all right
equally he was no Harry McCormack I'll
tell you that Jim could you tell it well
can you tell us something about parkland
or maybe how about Texas theater can you
give us some idea what to give us a real
good story parkland was never around
that day that I covered but the Texas
theater was but let me drop back just a
minute to say that while the toll 30 30
years takes on you I'm going to confide
that last night my upper left bridge
fell out huh so I ask your indulgence
the the fact that Tom Simmons is here is
representative of the Dallas news
editors and Buster has and Bill Evans I
still question it today why are they
assigned a police reporter that morning
on Friday to cover the president's
arrival at Dallas love Phil I could
frankly see no sense that because after
all I was covering the police and that
was not a matter for me to be at love
Phil I would have probably normally gone
up and joined my buddies at the police
headquarters for our first morning beer
but my wife doesn't know that but
nonetheless I did go out to love Hill
and it changed my life
Bob Wells talks about how the eloquently
was the arrival of the Kennedys is
exactly that way I left it with an
extremely warm feeling all I've seen is
a little Phil could you ever imagine
that returning down Stemmons that you'd
meet the motorcade Russian to love
Parkland Hospital and I knew something
was out of place
because the candy open limousine had the
one of the agents still clinging to the
back deck and I knew that was our place
but again they've talked about here this
morning about we didn't have technology
that you guys have got today so I I
didn't know what was going on I've got
to police headquarters has already
flipped over to Calif and heard that
shots been fired disbelief I hit stock
to ride with a former Dallas time cell
reporter coming out of the building the
police headquarters now a Dallas
sergeant Jerry Hill and we made our way
back down to the School Book Depository
and there I saw officers still holding
their shotguns up at the windows as if
they were expecting counter fire or what
and then the question about the chicken
bones came up and there's a
a statement about that later on and then
for some reason the report came out on
those squad car radios that a Dallas
officer was down in Oak Cliff and years
later I reflected why did I leave the
biggest story ever any news man could
cover knowing that shots have been fired
at existing president's motorcade but
for some reason I ran jump to the
backseat of another Dallas police car
driven by a sergeant and occupied by
captain we made our way into Oak Cliff
and we made our way into the Texas
theater I've got to say one time I did
get a chance to call my city desk from a
capitals mini-market Python and because
I knew that someone's going down in Oak
Cliff somebody had shot at Dallas
policemen and I wanted to photographer
because in those days spot a news
photographer Porter's always try to get
their spongy's photographers in line
first you could always get the story
later and I get Harvey bogan one of the
assistants the desk
editors and he wants to know what the
hell I'm doing in Oakland I got no
photographer the by that time I had to
rush back out and grab a ride in the
police car and we ended up to the Texas
theater and for some reason I went in
the balcony and there was a scuffle down
and the main Florida vanillish and I
appeared over the over the ledge and I
watched Dallas officers take the gun
down
I didn't know he was my steamed
colleague Kent Biffle only this morning
cleared up something I've never
understood as to how quickly we knew
there was Lee Harvey Oswald but once he
was brought to Dallas Police
Headquarters and the word came out he
was a Russian defected to Russia it
changed my attitude greatly I'll tell
you so I saw
worked the candy arrival and ended up in
Texas theater and again
özil was taken from the Texas theater in
a car that I had driven up in or had
ridden up in so again I was hitchhiking
this day I don't know who I hitchhiked
back in with thank you Jim appreciate it
mr. downtown Dallas mr. Ron McAllister
Jenkins Jones Smith whatever name he
used now huh well you uh we got at
Parkland yeah I was uh I started off
that day down to police headquarters we
knew right off that Heartland yeah yeah
we knew right off that something was
wrong though because Jim wasn't there
that's okay he was somewhere else yeah
but I was at the trademart with you and
followed the what was left of the
motorcade to Parkland Hospital in
somewhat of a high-speed run trying to
keep up and there was no possible way to
do that by the time I got the Parkland
couldn't even get in the front drive so
I said well I know another way so I went
around the back way through what they
call the doctor's entrance at that time
got around to the back side and then
came up on the emergency room from there
but as the reporters that were there
will tell you there was no way of
getting in of course to the emergency
room that was totally sealed off by the
time the bus and everyone else got there
so I figure well there's got to be
another way to get in here and find out
what's going on and since that was part
of my beat too I finally figured it out
I'd go around to what they call at that
time the DOA room which of course is
where they brought all of the the people
who didn't make it for emergency
treatment was a little late for that and
I quickly scooted around to the backside
and came in the back door and the lady
who ran that desk was named fern Elliott
I'm sure a lot of reporters will
remember and I asked her I said furna
said you know anything that's going on
she says no they're not telling me at
funny I says well I won't try to get
around there she says we're not gonna
get very far
yeah and she was right I turned the
corner and there were a couple of the
plainclothes men both armed with machine
guns and said sorry but we just can't
let you pass this point so I said well
all right we'll stay here then and
I stayed in the office there and while I
was in there and this was some time
later they wheeled in the body and I
asked one of the ambulance drivers who I
knew at that time I said where's this
coming from
he said I don't know he said we picked
this one up over to Texas theater over
in Oak Cliff area it's a police officer
his name is tippet and of course I knew
nothing about what was going on at the
Texas theater at that time because we
were pretty much in solitary in Parkland
well eventually it came around I got
back outside knowing I couldn't get
anything done there and shortly after
that the word came out about the fate of
the President and while Burton 2499
other reporters were the first to
announce the president's death I was the
twenty five hundred and first I never
did get to because my news director had
shown up by that time and he took it
upon himself to take over those duties
whereupon I found out later to my
chagrin that he took my mobile unit went
to his house and took a nap and I never
have figured that one out but we were
there at Parkland Hospital and then of
course came the announcement that the
president was dead and so we wrapped up
that as much as we possibly could of
course there were a lot of names being
bantered around there was the name of a
Catholic priest which escapes me at the
present time I think was something like
Father Huber and they said that he had
come out and unofficially stated that
the president was dead and then a short
time later of course we got the official
word so there was nothing left for me to
do but stay at Parkland Hospital and
cover the news conference which was by
that time being announced from the
governor governor Connally to get his
condition and that's where the only
positive thing of the whole day came for
me because I was right up on the front
of the room there holding a microphone I
was working for KPIX radio if any of you
remember the station back during the old
rock-and-roll Wars as I was holding the
microphone and the hospital officials
were giving the conditions of Governor
Connally and the type of wounds etc
I had on a watch my parents had given me
for graduation from high school and they
hadn't seen me or heard from me in about
a year and my mother knew I was okay cuz
she saw my arm sticking out there with
the watch in the microphone
yes so there was some good that came out
of it but the thing I think that struck
me most was what happened early that
morning we also watched the arrival of
Air Force One as it came down as Jim
said his life changed when he saw the
whole the elegance I guess is a good
word when the plane stopped the door
open
nobody really came out and then all of a
sudden
President Kennedy appeared and he had a
way of doing this like no one I have
ever seen before and it was a presence
bigger than life I never knew how tall
the man was or anything else but he
looked about seven feet tall when he
came out of that door all by himself and
then of course the first lady and I'll
never forget that shocking pink suit she
was wearing she came up beside him and
then of course they broke and they went
to the fence and started shaking hands
and you knew what a special person this
was later time later of course it was
you know it was a totally different day
you were there thank you very much yes
thank you
if I have to tell you about Tony zombie
we've all got problems because he was
Tony's as an institution here Las Vegas
he knew more about Dallas at night and
in any vampire in town but Tony had a
lot of experiences among one of them or
two of them occurred at Parkland that
day and Tony thank you and this
afternoon we're doing a panel on Jack
Ruby which was pretty much my
involvement in this and we'll leave that
for this afternoon
Ruby was in my office as a matter of
fact Wednesday before the Friday and
I'll tell about that this afternoon but
I went down to the Adolphus Hotel Friday
morning and Andy Anderson the manager of
the hotel was there was will Fritz who
was an FBI man good friend of ours brick
wall and Joe Peterson who had his show
there by the name of bottoms up
and an agent for Music Corporation of
America his name was Johnny hit and we
were going to watch the parade nandi
suggests he's let's go up to the
mezzanine there's a marquee over the
sidewalk and he said we'll get a great
view of the parade so we went up there
and we're waiting for the parade I don't
know how many of you remember honest Joe
the pawnbroker down on Elm Street well
we all said here comes the parade and it
was on his Joe and his in his station
wagon about two minutes before the
parade and everybody's all held you know
but eventually the parade came by and
and we were watching and as the
presidential limousine went by I was
holding a little transistor radio and I
turn to will Fritz and I said will he's
so damn wide open you know as a kid I
used to see path a news and they always
had Secret Service men hanging all over
the bumpers and on the back of the car
and all but this was totally wide open I
said well if this was a grenade I could
just lob it in that car and he says Tony
don't even talk like that
so they went on by and then we decided
to go into the Kings Club which was any
of the office on the mezzanine and have
a bite of lunch and as I walked in there
Chris Nelson the owner of the club said
there's a long-distance call for you I
used to eat there every day and if you
wanted me to I called the Kings Club and
I got on a phone and just as I started
to talk Chris came back into the office
and his lips were trembling I can see
him just as plain as day and his lips
were purple and tremble he says they
shot the president I slam down a
receiver and ran back to the news and
Johnny King the city editor was more or
less directing traffic and I was a
nightclub columnist which in the
journalistic profession is tantamount to
a piano player in a house of ill-repute
so I so I turn to Johnny and I said
listen I'm not a I'm not a front-page
reporter but I am a newspaperman I said
what can I do and Johnny said I go out
there and maybe you can take in some
film from the photographers or something
he says do whatever you can but at least
I had an assignment so I got back in my
car and I got out there about a quarter
of a mile from the hospital cars parked
all over the place I pulled into a empty
space and ran over him to the hospital
and I was at the emergency dock and the
first thing I saw was the limousine with
the roses in the backseat no I got up on
the emergency doc and started walking to
the emergency entrance and two Secret
Service men said where are you going
unless I'm going in the husband Hospital
say who are you some chonies happy with
the Dallas news let me see your press
pass well I never carried a press pass
because well I felt like I didn't need
one
I had a daily column and a TV show knew
everybody around town they wouldn't let
me in and I was the most frustrated
newspaper man in a war
standing out there on that dock knowing
that everybody else was in the hospital
and about that time and an O'Neill
ambulance pull up to the dock and backed
in and the driver and his helper got out
and opened a back door and I saw this
huge bronze casket and up until then
nobody knew for sure whether he was dead
or alive there are rumors that Connolly
who had been killed or was hurt and the
president wasn't hurt and then he was
hurt and all kind of conjecture when I
saw that casket I said he's dead and
they were trying to lift that casket
onto a gurney and they couldn't lift it
it was so heavy so the driver turned to
me says grab a corner we and I grabbed a
corner of the casket and fellows next to
me grabbed the corner and we lifted it
onto the gurney and I started to let go
but the Secret Service man the ones that
wouldn't let me and now to go and come
on come on come on so I just held on and
I figured boy I'm going to get in and I
did something that to this day I can't
explain as we're rolling that casket
into the hospital I reached underneath
it and I put my fingerprints as hard as
I could on the bottom of that casket
I'm still trying to explain why I did it
other than the fact I figure well he's
going to be in this casket and I want
him to know that Tony zoppi helped carry
the casket and if nothing else you know
I think that's the closest I can come to
explain but I got in the hospital now
they said follow the yellow line which
we didn't write down in a trauma room
and now I could really see the story of
the century you know and we got right up
to the door and a little Secret Service
fellow about 5 foot 8 I can see him just
as plain as day and he says we'll take
it from here gentlemen and I said oh no
we got it he says we'll take it from
here and I said don't press your luck
and I looked over there was a bank of
phones on the opposite wall so I went
over to one of the phones and a man
answered they gave me the number to
Dallas news I said get me to Dallas news
he says get the hell off this
and the line went dead the FBI learned
later had it tied up all the phones but
there was a stairwell
and down at the bottom of the stairs I
noticed this girl at a switchboard the
old time plugin switchboards and so I
ran down there and I says I'm Tony zoppi
with the Dallas yeah I read your column
every morning I said do me a favor get
me a phone and get me to Dallas news she
said go in that office and use that
black phone on a desk so I went in there
she put the call through and Johnny king
who had sent me out there rather
reluctantly he answered the phone I said
Johnnie this is Tony zoppi the president
is dead which made me to twenty five
hundred and second dependents so he says
how the hell do you know because he had
all his top people out there and I said
I just carried in his casket and Johnny
said you sure
and I says I'm positive Johnny he's dead
he said you better be right and I said
I'm right because they were figuring on
putting out a an extra and they had to
make damn sure because nobody in the at
the news at that time it hurts heard the
heat confirmation and I don't want to
run over my time because I have a lot of
Jack Ruby stories always to be continued
right
thank you Tony
Hugh Ainsworth has already been
introduced
fabulous background has been relayed to
you but I talked to you into maybe
adding a couple of PS as to what we have
going here this morning Thank You Bert I
I was just going to I won't take much
time because my panel Randall was wrong
we're in trouble here but I mentioned
after we left the the Depository
building we heard about an officer been
shot and I ran over there and
interviewed people got with to channel 8
people Victor Autzen and I can't
remember the other one and we we drove
like madman to get over there
interviewed all those people and from
there there was a tip that the who the
suspect whoever it was was in a
furniture store whole furniture store
run Jefferson and I've asked I've been
asked a lot of times was I ever scared
and I was not scared when the shooting
went off because with so many people I
guess I felt the odds against him
getting me might be you know several
hundred to one but the only time I was
scared I went in that furniture store
and there were six or seven eight cops
whatever some plain clothes the couple
in uniform and all of a sudden we're
going through and it's just stacked up
it's Dusty's dirty it's not a place of
business it's the stories furnished
place and all of a sudden somebody comes
piling through the second floor up to
hear his feet coming down and I thought
oh my god that's him whoever he is you
know that's the guy that kills a cop and
I looked around and everywhere I saw
everyone had a gun except me and at that
point I was scared
pretty soon we got out of there there
was nothing to accept cops looking after
the cops but soon we got a report that
the Texas theater was suspect entered
there and all cars and a facility should
go there it was only four or five blocks
so I ran like the devil and got in there
just about I would assume just less than
a minute before Oswald was captured I
remember looking through the thing and
already that the lights had been brought
up a little bit it was about half lights
on and there were people coming up both
aisles and I noticed one time they
stopped somebody else I guess
Rosewall off they knew where he was
because the man that had fingerprinted
her had pointed a finger at him
and which resulted in the police being
called with Johnny brewer who had a shoe
store four doors down and he had seen
Oswald cringe and sort of off to one
side as the people that the cars with
sirens went by and after they too went
by then he saw he that he followed that
Oswald out to the thing thought it was
unusual
so him go in the theater he was one
later went in the back and told the
police through the thing where that's
him there but but they didn't want to go
straight to Oswald because they didn't
know if he was armed or not but then
they jumped him there were six or seven
total I guess I have talked to probably
five of them I think there were two
others that I did not talk to Oswald
made quite a quite a fight for a little
guy and I remember him keep he was
yelling I protest this police brutality
he said that three or four times one
thing I never understood it was a
policeman as they brought him out there
was a policeman with a big Stetson and
kept holding it over his face so that
some of the photographers didn't get his
face for a while I never understood why
he was protecting him in that way
afterward I don't know where I got this
I still had asked Jim Yul if he told me
but later that afternoon I started going
around to the places Oswald lived and I
don't know where I got those addresses I
really don't but I remember one time was
very embarrassing I went to one of the
places Oswald believed on Neeley Street
and I knocked and I knocked and I
knocked because I wanted to find out if
anybody knew him as you know this man
who sort of a stage of undress came to
the door very very angry at me and spoke
Spanish did not speak much English and
he could not understand why I was there
and I couldn't understand what he was
doing and and I looked and I saw you had
a lady friend that he was doing with
and I got out of there in a hurry
earlier I had gone by I'll make is very
brief but I went by the 1026 Beckley and
interviewed the the lady that was the
landlady there at Great Lengths
and one thing she tried to give me the
signature thing that Oswald had signed a
and OHV and she said the FBI just left
and they didn't take this who you want
this do you want this I said no I know I
don't want this you but they'll be back
for it of it but that's that's about the
extent of that day for me thank you very
much you thank all of you appreciate you
letting me hold your feet to the fire
because these guys could dig oh they
have great stories could going on all
day long but thank you very much for
your patience and your attendance here
and and I'm sure that mr. Payne has the
drill for the rest of the day and uh
thank you
okay thanks Bert uh don't forget those
ballots as you go out there there'll be
a table on your